Again,
I want to thank you all for and Browny.
You're doing a heck of a job.
FEMA directors working twenty four.
Joining me today is the former director
of the Federal Emergency Management
Agency,
better known as fema,
as well as the host of the Michael Brown
radio show.
Michael Brown.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Hey Dave.
Good to see you.
Good to be with the.
You know,
this is the first time we've ever done
this where we played a ten second clip.
Let me get.
Do you have any idea where I can.
I can't even imagine what you might be
talking about.
Yes.
I struggled with it for a little while
because I thought,
do I want to go right in and throw this
right at him?
Sort of the infamous moment or do we
want to ease into it,
but then I thought,
let's just.
Let's just get it out there because it
is what it is.
It's a seminal moment in my life.
It the.
There's,
there's before that moment.
Then after that moment.
Yeah.
Alright.
There are many,
many reasons that I'm glad to be sitting
here with you because I think we're
going to get into so many of the things
that we talked about on the show all the
time about the role of government and
the difference between local government
and federal government,
all of these agencies and red tape and
all that,
but also that for that moment and what
happened for the months and probably
years after that and actually even I
when I was googling you this morning,
all the 10 year anniversary people that
were still pissed at you and all that
stuff.
It has a lot to do with your sort of the
general outrage culture and blame
culture and all of that.
So we're going to do a lot here.
So first let's just start with that
moment though and then and then I want
to do everything else back.
Sure.
Okay.
Just tell me a little bit about the days
leading up to Hurricane Katrina.
It became clear to me probably within.
Well,
it came clear to me the day after the
storm made landfall because I was on a
Black Hawk helicopter with former
senator Mary Landrieu,
and we were supposed to be going
straight to the superdome to meet with
Mayor Nagin,
who I always like to joke is remind
people he's still in federal prison and
in I'm sitting there and I'm not.
I'm just kind of reading my notes from
my staff and I look out the helicopter
and I realized that we're going the
wrong direction across lake
pontchartrain and I asked the pilot,
where were you going?
And he said,
well,
the senator has asked that we go check
her cabin before we go to the superdome.
I was livid,
so now I have a sitting United States
senator next to me who's just overridden
what I said we need to be doing and what
the priorities are.
I have the governor sitting next to her
who doesn't have the wherewithal to say
to the senator,
you know what?
Your cabin is not our priority.
The priority is the people of New
Orleans.
It was a moment that I realized that I
had walked into a state that was so much
more corrupt.
I've been involved in politics and so I
was literally six years old that was
just so corrupt and it was so
dysfunctional that I knew that
everything that I had in my head about
how things should operate,
we're going to start going out the
window.
Okay.
I think that's actually a perfect story
to now start with your childhood.
Let's just,
let's just get a little bias because I
think that's really interesting and what
led you to eventually be the director of
Fema and then we'll go through
everything else.
So just tell me a little bit about
growing up.
Was Your family political?
What sort of got you into this world
like?
Yeah.
My family was kind of political.
When I think about it.
I mean my mom is 86,
87 years old and she still works for the
election board.
She still does the little local
elections in the little town that I grew
up in.
I think you'd have to be over 80 to work
at the electrical.
Exactly.
I think it is a requirement,
she's been doing this since she was in
high school,
but when the first Republican governor
of Oklahoma was running,
he was state party chairman,
a guy by the name of Henry Belding,
uh,
was coming out to the Oklahoma panhandle
and they recruited me at six years old
to be the little kid to him the push
cards out as he walked these rural
streets of Oklahoma.
So I just grew up in this political
family that was always involved and of
course,
you know,
involved in student council and,
in college and Young Republicans know
all of that.
And so politics has just always been a
part of my life and I always thought I
understood politics until I got to
Washington DC until Hurricane Katrina.
And it just gave me an entirely
different perspective.
But anyway,
long story short,
you know,
I took the typical route,
uh,
graduated from high school to my,
my,
my wife is my childhood sweetheart.
Her Dad actually delivered me.
Wow.
That's the kind of small town we grew up
in.
Wow.
Uh,
we've been married for,
Gosh,
40 some years.
I don't want to say how many,
um,
uh,
and,
you know,
went to law school,
raised two children,
very successful,
very,
very successful children,
and just had a pretty normal life except
that I knew I wanted to be a lawyer,
but I always had this thought process
that you never turned down an aisle,
you always looking at an opportunity and
if an opportunity looks good,
you take that opportunity even if it's
off the path you thought you were going
to take.
And so that's led me to these
incredible,
incredible experiences in my life that
most people don't do because they become
lawyers and all they do is practice law
their entire life.
That's not me.
So what was the first one of those
moments when you thought,
wow,
there's a good opportunity?
A little little to the right off that
exit.
I'm the alum Republican Party,
came to me and asked me to run for
Congress back in 1988,
promised me all of this money that they
were going to.
In fact,
that governor,
who was the first Republican governor,
went on to be a US senator and then came
back.
He was a big supporter of me,
but I was running can rebuild them,
former US senator.
He was involved in the Panama Canal
treaties and everything,
but,
um,
the Oakland Republican Party recruited
me and said,
come on,
we really want you to run,
and so I let ego get in the way.
And I ran against a 12 term Democrat,
incumbent in a gerrymandered district
where I got my butt beat,
but it was,
um,
it was an experience that again,
most Americans never do.
Most Americans never throw their hat in
the ring and actually go out and say,
I'm going to do it.
And I would encourage people,
whether it's a city council,
county commissioner,
state representative,
whatever it is,
if you don't like the way things are
going,
if you're going to bitch about it,
I don't want to hear about it unless
you're actually involved doing
something.
Doesn't mean you have to run for office,
but you gotta be involved.
Yeah.
It's so funny after the ringer that
you've been through,
I guess it's that maybe it's not funny.
It's either ironic or perfectly politik
that that's still is your message as
someone that you know,
we sort of put up as as the poster boy
for everything that's wrong with Dave.
Let me tell you,
it may be poetic,
but it.
Sorry,
I should quit pointing to the lawyer.
Yeah,
it is.
I can tell you so many stories about how
dysfunctional state I've been involved.
I was a city councilman,
A.
I've worked with state legislature as
the finance director.
Then you go on A.
I'm the Under Secretary of Homeland
Security.
I have seen,
I have been inside the bowels of the
government and I can tell you how it
works and it is not what most American
instinct and we're going to get to all
of that.
So the Under Secretary of Homeland
Security,
that is the director of Fema,
right.
That's the.
That's just sort of the more technical
term for that.
Were you involved in the administration
before nine slash 11 or was it after
that?
That's when Bush know Peggy for those.
I was there.
Yeah,
and in fact I was in Montana getting
ready to deliver a speech to the
national emergency managers association
about the role of Fema and terrorism on
nine slash 11,
2011.
So you were the director of him at that
time?
I was,
I was the general counsel at that time
and we ended up on a c 1:35
going back to Andrews Air Force Base.
Uh,
Joe Wall Ball,
who was the director at the time?
Uh,
immediate went,
went to ground zero on that Wednesday
morning and I went to the White House
and just spend the next,
gosh,
seems like year,
just day in and day out.
Just planning,
getting ready for we didn't know what.
Yeah.
What's the one thing that really sticks
out in your mind about that day itself?
For the first time you are flying alone.
There are no planes in the sky.
You're flying alone.
Some airman asked me if I went to go
down in the tanker bay and and just
watch as we fly across Middle America
and I'm listening on the,
on the headset and the chatter you hear
are among the fighter jets that are
flying around the country and when I
landed it was not knowing.
It was like there was this blank wall in
front of us.
None of us knew what was going to happen
next and so we meet in the Roosevelt
Room in the situation room that next
morning to get briefing by the CIA and
everybody else and I remember just this,
this quietness in the room that
everybody knew that none of us knew what
we were facing.
Yeah.
Was there a feeling that George W dot
Bush was the right guy to handle this
because for all the frustrations that
people may have with him and that
perhaps you have related to some degree
with Katrina and we can get into that.
Right.
I do remember at the time,
and I lived in New York City at the
time,
so I was there for nine slash 11.
Right.
Family was there.
My grandma was there,
my,
my dad,
um,
I do remember that between George w Bush
at the time,
but particularly Giuliani,
I think there was at least a feeling
that these guys are sort of the right
people to be handling this at the time.
Certainly Giuliani,
at least from a New Yorker's
perspective.
Did you,
did you feel that,
did people feel that within the
government that,
like,
that Bush was kind of able to handle
this or have the right skillset to
handle this?
Yes,
it was for me it was more than most.
Um,
I mean,
I can still remember vividly that in the
Roosevelt Room you've got Colin Powell,
you got Donald Rumsfeld,
Condi Rice shouldn't have andy card,
so you have all these heavy hitters.
And then here's little old me sitting at
the table too.
And I remember watching because I just,
I'm an,
I'm an observer of people and I remember
watching all of them and there was none
of the usual because I had been in these
meetings before and there was none of
the usual,
hey,
how you do?
And everybody was at the table.
Everybody was reading their briefing,
everybody was trying to understand.
We know that we always referred to the
president as the boss.
We know the boss is going to ask some
tough questions and we know we're not
going to have answers and that's indeed
what happened.
Know we had theories,
we have ideas,
we have plans,
but nobody really knew for certain what
was next.
Yeah.
And especially in those first few days
where we didn't know if another attack
was coming or anything like what was
actually the job of Fema for those first
few days.
We are,
um,
we're the nation's federal first
responder.
We coordinate all of,
for example,
if the Pentagon ground zero,
our job was to make sure that we have
all the urban search and rescue teams
deployed,
that we take care of the firefighters,
we provide all the equipment,
we provide the training,
we do all of that stuff.
So our job was to clean up ground zero.
Our job was at the Pentagon to help
clean that up.
And what was fascinating about it was
normally you go to a disaster.
It's not also a crime scene,
but in this case,
both the Pentagon and in and in and in
Pennsylvania and obviously in ground
zero,
they were also crime scenes,
so we now had to coordinate talking
about federalism.
So now we had to coordinate,
you know,
the federal government,
state government,
local government,
and on top of that we had to coordinate
with the CIA,
the FBI,
the NSA,
and everybody else who's doing all of
the forensic work.
How does that go?
I mean,
one of the things we talk about here a
lot is sort of the unwieldy giant
government we have right now,
sort of all the middlemen and
bureaucrats.
They get in the way of everything.
I mean,
how did it really go up?
That's your job.
Here's what's fascinating.
When the governments under pressure like
that,
everybody does what you have to meet.
My mother in law had to say that drove
my drives,
my wife crazy shoot,
she's now deceased,
but it was,
you know,
sometimes you just have to do what you
have to do and when,
when a crisis hits of that magnitude,
it's all hands on deck and if you need
to break the rules,
people are willing to break the rules to
make things happen.
So I would say that in,
in,
in those intense moments,
that's probably when the government
tends to do the best job because
everybody's trying their hardest to do
what's best for the country.
Yeah.
So how soon after that did a debbie tap
you to be the head of FEMA?
Uh,
let's see.
So,
uh,
shortly after I became the deputy
director,
I would say like just a couple of months
later,
I went from general counsel to deputy
director of when they announced the
creation of the department will story
about the creation of dhs.
So they're going to create the DHS.
So w points me to the transition team,
we're one of five people putting
together the department.
And I apologized to the nation for that
because I've got lots of regrets about
dhs.
I'm happy to talk.
We will.
Um,
and then soon thereafter all ball left
and that's when I became the under
secretary and the director of Fema.
So probably within,
Gosh,
a year.
Yeah.
Oh.
And then just,
it's the mailman story.
You know,
you start in the mail room and you work
your way up.
Yeah.
And on the two years after that,
then the other crisis,
certainly.
So tell me a little bit about your
regrets creating the Department of
Homeland Security.
Here's a backstory first that most
people don't know.
The administration was opposed to the
creation of the department.
We thought it was a mistake,
huge mistake.
We're going to create this massive
bureaucracy,
why things are working the way they're
supposed to work.
But Congress felt this political desire
that you have to be seen doing
something.
So once congress said,
hey,
we're going to move forward with
legislation than the White House says,
oh my God,
now we've got to get in front of this
because we want to control it and mold
it in our own view,
not congress's view,
because in effect they don't want to get
legislation put on his desk that he lido
and then it's like he's against almost.
Exactly.
So.
So our job was an example of how screwed
so,
so I'm thrown me and four other guys
with Clay Johnson,
the president's best friend,
college roommate,
a deputy director of omb were thrown
together to create this massive new
bureaucracy by taking 22 different
cultures,
22 different cultures,
22 different organizations and throwing
them in together and trying to make it
work.
What are a couple of those organizations
that were thrown in there?
I mean,
it's everybody,
right?
Well,
it was secret secret service.
What the hell,
Secret Service and homeland security.
Uh,
the,
the coast guard,
the coast guard has this kind of
schizophrenia role.
They've worked for homeland security,
yet they're subjected to the military
code of conduct and they kind of
technical work for pimp for the
Pentagon,
so we've got all of the.
You've got that,
you have ice customs and border patrol
immigration,
a different grants from the Department
of Justice Fema.
Everybody had a different culture and my
objection was you can't throw different
cultures together and really expect them
to work either in the short term and the
longterm.
Every organization,
corporate,
private,
governmental has a culture and trying to
meld those is the one of the most
difficult things to do.
Look,
I love Carly Fiorina.
Consider her a friend,
but they brought in to talk to us about
how to do mergers and acquisitions and
I'm thinking,
wait a minute,
the HP and merger and acquisition,
that didn't seem to go too well and
you're going to tell us how to do this
22 government agency thing.
I mean,
that's one objection.
The second objection was,
you know,
we got to airports with a major concern
and for whatever reason we wanted to
blame the private contractors who have a
vested interest in making sure that the
airlines are secure,
right?
But that's not good enough.
Instead,
let's fire all of them and let's create
this massive new bureaucracy called the
Tsa.
And I'm,
I'm like the kid in the back of the
classroom that keeps raising his hand
and say,
but professor y w,
how's that gonna work?
Um,
but there was just this way.
What would happen when he said something
like that?
Because now I think in 2018,
if you say something about the Tsa,
most people that agree with you,
that really ridiculous,
the reaction was always,
well,
we're going to meet your objection by
doing y.
and I had been around the block long
enough to know that that answer was bs.
But when you're the one person out of
five,
you're out voted.
So you,
you,
you tend to.
There's a great Washington Post story
that talks about brown as the
bureaucratic infighter.
And I was in the post,
writes it as if that's a bad thing and I
considered a badge of honor because I
was fighting for just the reality that
when you tell me that putting these,
deploy these different agencies
together,
there's going to be budget neutral.
That's BS.
When you tell me you're going to create
Tsa,
but you're going to prevent them from
ever being a union.
That's bs because I just know how
government metastasizes.
And so the TSA has turned out to be what
I thought it was the dysfunction within
dhs.
While it may be minimally better,
it's still a dysfunctional organization.
So let's back up for a second,
because you mentioned that before this,
the security.
Was it all done by private companies
before the TSA?
That's almost hard to believe.
Or was it all done by private?
Yes.
The,
uh,
the airlines who have,
who has the most now you think about
just trying to figure out what's the
best way to put a program together.
Well,
who has the most interest in making
certain that they're planes are never
hijacked or flown into buildings.
Oh,
the airlines.
Why don't we let them decide security,
because what do they have?
Competing interests.
They want to make sure that their planes
are secure,
their passengers are safe,
but that the security operates in the
most efficient and effective way.
Now you tell me government's going to
care about those three things be as
well.
It's also interesting because it's like
what a great lady used competition in
the right sense where it's like this
airline that's doing it the right way
where they could go,
you know what?
Look at our marks on security,
so we're charging you $5 more than a lot
of people wouldn't have a problem with
it.
It would.
It would be a beautiful thing.
I didn't realize that it was fully
private before that.
Yes.
Wow.
So any other.
I mean that's a pretty big issue,
but any other big regrets related to.
Well,
for example,
we have within fema what was called the
catastrophic disaster response group.
Everything is an acronym,
so it was,
it was the Crg and because the FEMA
director under under federal law,
when in times of disaster reports
directly to the president,
you're the of representative,
so this cdr,
gee,
when there was a disaster,
like nine slash 11,
we brought all of the cabinet
departments and agencies together,
so usually had the deputy secretaries
there because they were there on behalf
of their bosses and we would deconflict
policy.
We would set priorities and if State
Department wanted to do one thing,
but dod you wanted to do another and ag
wanted to do something else.
That was where we got all of those
deconflicted because the FEMA director
had the authority of the president
sitting in that room.
Well,
that's gone away now and you've thrown
these all together and I've always said
if you want to find out whether a
disaster is being handled properly or
not,
or any sort of crisis,
this could be in the private sector to
ask this question,
who's in charge?
If you can't answer the question,
who's in charge,
then it's a cluster.
Is there an inherent sort of.
There's a conflict here which is that
basically you're taking government
people and for someone like you that
maybe wanted less government,
and I think this is what you're really
saying about Bush at the beginning of
this.
I didn't want this,
the administration,
he didn't write it,
but government,
and this is the problem with
Libertarians in general,
like people that want less government.
Well,
if you're in the government,
it's hard to look around the office and
be like,
guys,
you know,
most of us probably shouldn't even be
here.
You know,
we're,
we're going to need new jobs guys.
So in Fema first started in 1979 under
Jimmy Carter,
they had a policy of providing ice to
hospitals so that lactating mothers had
a place where they could keep milk,
where you could keep insulin and other
medicines that require pharmaceuticals
or require refrigeration.
That ice was for hospitals to provide
their local communities a place for the
medicines to say stay cool and safe and
everything else that has metastasized,
which is my favorite word of government.
It has metastasized now to where in a
disaster we,
we provide every Tom,
Dick and Harry two bags of ice so that
they can keep their hamburger cold or
there or the coors beer cold.
And I went to Congress and said,
this is out control.
We're spending tens of millions of
dollars on ice so that a private citizen
can keep their food cold.
Is that really a government function?
Even talking to conservatives on the
hill,
let alone Democrats or liberals or
anybody else.
I was a heretic because we can't support
that because that's taking something
away from our constituents.
Would you reckon that you realize it's a
waste?
Right?
Why should we be doing that?
Well,
we can't stop it now.
Yeah,
it's fascinating.
And then you just get all these sort of
middle management,
Kratz men.
No,
nobody's going to give up that.
Right.
So,
uh,
was there anything else major between,
for you professionally between nine
slash 11 and Katrina,
like what were,
what were you doing before that was
instilled chess related and we had the
Columbia space shuttle disaster,
which we had to coordinate with NASA
because NASA was in shock.
So we had to help them do all the search
and rescue from California to Texas.
We had a huge wildfires in California
that were just massive.
Luckily they've recently experienced,
we had fires throughout the west,
flooding in the Midwest.
We had the tsunami in Southeast Asia.
I mean I could go on and on and on.
Yes.
My life was just full of hell from nine
slash 11 on.
So until that,
until the Katrina moment.
Yes.
What was the general feeling about you?
Because then now we'll get into this
where you were then used as.
Well,
I was competent,
knew what I was doing.
The White House always turned to me to,
to get things done.
Uh,
it.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I'll,
I'll take,
I'll take it,
I'll take your word for it.
But by and large you were thought of as
a competent executive.
And everything was okay,
so now,
now feeding habits.
I love the story that you told right at
the beginning because what a,
what a perfect story of like just awful
abusive power.
Go check out my home instead of,
you know,
the,
the disaster areas and all that kind of
stuff.
Uh,
how does it,
there was a certain amount of time we
knew that this thing was going to be a
crazy,
right?
I mean,
how long before it happened?
It was going to be crazy because we had,
I had gone to Congress and ask for an
appropriation.
I actually wanted to spend some tax
money to plan for 10 truly catastrophic
disasters.
Something like a hurricane.
You,
your former New Yorker.
Can you imagine a category five going up
the Hudson river?
Can you imagine something happening to
the LNG natural gas,
a port in Boston,
a terrorist incident there.
Imagine the big one hitting California
or the new magid fault.
Imagine because New Orleans a Fishbowl,
a category five filling up New Orleans.
So Congress had given me money to start
doing catastrophic planning for these
kinds of things.
New Orleans was the first one we picked
and when we did a tabletop exercise to
see if we could coordinate the response,
the table top exercise fell apart,
Dave,
so I knew probably nine,
12 months before Katrina actually
occurred that we weren't ready.
So what does that actually mean when
you're doing a table top exercise that
that's just coordinating all the,
all the players in the room and you
pretend like you're going through a
disaster.
So what?
What are you doing?
What are the conflicts?
How do we deconflict all of these policy
issues?
Do we have enough food?
How do we get dod to dod?
Have enough equipment on hand,
Gideon food supplies and everything
else.
You exercise that around the table and
Louisiana fell apart.
Yeah.
Wouldn't work.
Was it right at the beginning of it that
you realized how severe it was?
I've been criticized because in May of
2005,
I had my wife.
This is before.
Before busy for Katrina?
Yeah.
It may of 2005.
Several Friends of mine,
including Colin Powell,
had said,
you know what?
It's probably time to leave and I,
I asked them,
seriously,
why is it,
well,
you've done everything that you can do
in terms of trying to mold dhs into what
you think it should be and nothing else
is going to happen.
It is what it is that you have.
You have fought the good fight.
Uh,
you've been here six years,
you know,
and of course my wife was,
we,
it's time to go back to Colorado to go
back to Colorado.
And so I told Andy Card,
the White House chief of staff in
malleable five that I wanted to resign
and go back to Colorado.
And what typically happens,
Andy said,
can you wait till Labor Day and go
through one more hurricane season for us
and that will give us time to find a
replacement.
Now when the president asks you to stay
for five more months,
sure,
I can do that,
man.
Labor Day.
What?
What was the day that Katrina hit?
It was August 29th.
August 29 Labor Day,
whatever it is,
eight days later.
Um,
okay.
So,
so it hits.
I mean,
I can remember watching everything on
CNN at the time.
Uh,
you mentioned Nagan.
Who is the mayor?
Uh,
mayor of New Orleans.
Lauren's.
How chaotic was it to coordinate?
You've already,
after you said this,
this initial test had failed about.
It was for.
It was a,
it was virtually impossible.
So I landed the superdome.
The superdome.
Well,
let's,
let's go back a step before I actually
went to New Orleans before the storm
made landfall,
Max Mayfield,
who was the director of the National
Hurricane Center fellow Okie.
He and I go on the phone together and we
knew how bad the storm is going to be,
but we could not get the attention of
state officials and frankly we couldn't
get the attention of the dod and State
Department,
other people that would be playing a
role.
How is that possible?
You now had this new dhs that was
supposed to be cool because who's in
charge?
I remember who's in charge.
Well,
everybody's now competing for their
pecking order because of dhs.
So I tell Max Mayfield,
would you please explain this?
I'm going to have bushes and Crawford.
He'll be on civic call,
this top secret phone conference,
video and everything,
and I'll have the mayor,
the governor of all the Gulf states,
their job will be there for Florida a
and I need you to read them the riot act
about how bad this is going to be,
and he did,
and then I pulled out an engineering
report that said the New Orleans
superdome cannot even withstand a
category three based upon engineering
reports,
and the mayor just announced that he's
going to use the superdome is a shelter
of last resort.
I'm screaming on this call and you can't
do that.
That's a huge mistake.
Blah,
blah,
blah.
At this point,
what?
What category did they think it was
gonna be?
We thought it was gonna be a fight when
it actually hit.
It was a three,
but as we all know is still ripped off
the roof of the.
Of the superdome?
No.
So I knew going in,
it was gonna be bad.
I say all that to lead to this one
point,
the day that I'm leaving to fly to to
baton rouge.
I remember exactly where I was.
I was on one 95 going around the,
uh,
the Pentagon and I called Joe Hagan,
the deputy chief of staff to telling
that I'm headed to Andrews.
I'm going down,
we're doing everything we can and I
said,
Joe,
but this is going to be a cluster
because I can't get stuff coordinated
now.
And the storm hasn't even hit.
And because I had already told them I
wanted to leave.
I said in an email to the and hey,
can I quit now?
And of course everybody picks it up.
Oh look,
Brown doesn't care.
He's,
he wants to quit before the storm even
hit.
That's fascinating.
I mean,
I remember that.
Sure.
Yeah.
And um,
I mean,
you were just being sarcastic.
I'm a sarcastic guy.
Yeah.
I'm a total smart ass.
And so I had already agreed to stay
through Labor Day.
I knew I was walking into a buzzsaw and
I'm telling Hagen,
Hey,
can I quit now?
And of course,
the New York Times,
you know,
for years,
all of my emails,
they see the jokes that I crack because
let me tell you something,
not to get off the subject here go,
but when,
when people are suffering and people
that are the rescue workers,
the firefighters that are taking people
off roofs that are taking them out of
flooded homes,
they're working their asses off,
they're tired,
they're worn out,
they're stressed out.
You know what the best thing to do is
give them a little humor.
Yeah,
show them.
Show a little humanity.
It's my father in law was a smoke,
told you,
delivered me,
and he was a surgeon.
He used to talk about how he would
relieve stress in the our by cracking
jokes and I've always thought that the
best way to manage people in a time of
stress is to remind them of their
humanity.
Make them laugh,
and if they can laugh for five seconds,
that gets the endorphins running and
they can go out and keep working 24
hours a day,
seven days a week.
And I was criticized for joking.
Well,
you know about school because I've been
asked before.
Well,
would you take any of those emails back?
Not on one of them,
because you know what,
that made a staffer smile that made
somebody laugh and if you don't
understand the context within which it
was made,
then you are deliberately just trying to
make hay out of something.
All right,
so let's get back to that 10 seconds of
video.
Know the exact line.
Even though everyone says it's a heck of
a job,
they don't even get that right.
He actually said,
Brownie,
you're doing a heck of A.
Yeah,
I just want to clean that up for him
because even that line,
they don't get it.
Right,
right.
Okay.
How many days into the hurricane was
that?
Oh Gosh.
I want to say it was maybe four,
maybe five days.
I've kind of,
I conflate time,
but four or five years.
Okay,
so four or five days.
You know what?
Now I watched plenty of other video
today of what you were doing at the time
and you're standing there.
People can see this on youtube.
You're standing there with giant maps of
the whole area.
He was very clear to me at least
watching it now that you had total
command of where things were and who was
supposed to be,
where,
where water was going to hit harder.
And you know,
Bush,
you know,
to his credit,
he,
it seemed that he was listening along
with us and you know,
doing the best job I think that he
could,
uh,
after.
Was it a,
was it three minutes after he says that,
that you realized there that the media
went crazy with it?
No,
it was the minute he was,
the minute he said it because here's
what you don't know what you,
what most people don't know is that I
had told the I called Air Force One and
said when he lands and gets here,
I need five minutes before we do any
sort of public photo op.
And when you,
even at my level to the under secretary,
even when you say I gotTa have five
minutes with the president,
they still want to know why.
And I said,
because he's got to understand before he
walks in front of cameras,
how bad things are in New Orleans
because we're gonna leave that Air
National Guard base,
get on marine one and we're going to fly
to New Orleans and he's going to start
seeing how screwed up it is in New
Orleans and I want to make sure he
understands that before he gets there.
So sure.
We got plenty of time.
So we walk into the green room.
I'm just starting to talk to the
president and they come in and say we
gotta get moving presses out here.
We're already running late and they pull
him out and I don't have time to brief
him or how bad it is.
So the moment.
And here's what really happened.
Bob Riley,
who was the governor of Alabama,
former congressman,
good friend of mine,
we were doing great male,
a Bama thing for perfect and Alabama
perfect.
Things were very good in Mississippi.
It was just Louisiana.
So Bob Riley being the supportive guy
that he is said,
oh,
by the way,
Mr President,
I just want you to know that the team is
doing a great job in Alabama.
And that's when the president said,
boom,
slap me in the gut.
And it was that moment,
Dave,
that I knew.
Oh my God,
now three things have happened.
The press knows that I've got a
relationship with the president that I
have a nickname.
So I'm one of the few people in the
inner circle that has a nickname,
uh,
to the press,
knows how bad things are in New Orleans.
And now both me and the boss looked like
we're totally out of touch about what's
happening down in the Gulf.
God,
I mean,
there's so much there when you really
realize how this was happening,
I was,
if you watch that closely,
you'll see me grimace because I was just
like,
holy.
Yeah.
So okay.
So once that happened,
how much of what your job became was
just dealing with media craziness,
total,
total.
Not just the media,
but now with a secretary of Homeland
Security,
Michael Chertoff,
who have never done any sort of
operations in his life.
He was an appellate court judge and
appellate court judge has clerks that
bring your briefs and say,
here's what we think your decisions
should be.
You sit behind the desk,
you take your time.
You don't realize that if you put off a
decision for 30 minutes in the middle of
a disaster,
that translates to three hours and that
costs lives.
So now I'm dealing with a Boston DC that
doesn't have a clue what he's doing,
who's mad at me because I'm on a Gulf
stream trying to get from mobile to Gulf
port to Baton Rouge,
to New Orleans and trying to keep my
fingers on everything going on.
Who tells me,
I'm tired of you flying around because I
can't find you and I'm thinking,
you can't find me.
I'm on a government.
Gulf stream has got satellite.
You can find me anywhere in the world if
you want to.
So tells me to plant my button in baton
rouge.
And I turned to my staff and say,
this is the beginning of the end
thereafter.
Me,
the media is after me,
Chertoff's after me.
They're looking for a scapegoat.
I'm not that stupid.
I mean I know what's going on.
Yeah.
Are.
Are there any points of criticism during
that time that you think are.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
I have a friend who is a psychiatrist at
the Kennedy School of government and the
school public health.
And I asked him one time,
I said there was a point during Katrina
where you haven't known me but a few
minutes now,
but I think you can tell I'm a pretty
type a person person.
Pretty energetic.
I'm pretty engaged in whatever I do.
I'm passionate about what I do.
And I asked my buddy,
I said,
so I know that there was a point where I
was just frozen.
I literally could not make a decision
what?
What happens?
He drew me a cartoon and it's a car,
you know,
the great wizard of Oz.
Well,
it's a picture of me in the first panel
pushing all these buttons and levers and
turning wheels and stuff.
And in the second panel,
I'm staring at that same group of
buttons like what's going on.
And in the third panel I've gone around
look behind and over wires have been
cut.
And he says that physiologically,
whether it's,
it's a,
it's ptsd,
it's a phenomena in the brain that when
we are trained,
like if I,
if I have trained myself,
that when I tell my staff,
do x,
I expect x to happen.
When you and I turned on these lights or
flip a switch,
we expect the lights to come on.
Now you add all the physical stress,
the emotional stress and nothing is
working.
The brain starts to shut down and I will
freely admit.
And this is why I,
I to this day,
I saw a firefighter the other day on the
street was having lunch.
And I walked up to him and I said,
what are you doing?
We've been doing training and,
and uh,
I'm taking the guys out for lunch.
And I said,
well,
you don't know who I am,
but let me just tell you that,
uh,
you know,
making sure those guys have time off and
that they get rest.
That's the most important thing you can
do because if they don't get rest when
they're fighting the fires,
they themselves can become victims of
that disaster.
So we've got to learn to train ourselves
that when we're under that kind of
stress,
you have to be able to step back.
And this is what I speak about
resilience.
I've learned to try to teach audiences
that we all have a network and what we
have to do is learn that when we find
ourselves in those moments that were
either not making the right decisions or
we're not making decisions,
we need some external force to come in
and kind of slapped some sense into us
and say,
change your perspective.
What I see is this.
If somebody has helped me do that during
Katrina,
might've still had the presidential bus
run me over,
but at least I would have known why and
what was happening.
But is that almost counter to the way a
sort of big government has to operate
you course it is.
You can't assume people are running
around smacking people and trying to get
him to wake up because the machine is so
stiff,
but what?
I needed a and you could.
My very best friend and my lawyer,
Andy Lester,
who went through all the congressional
hearings with me to this day,
he'll tell you that he regrets not
getting in his car and driving to baton
rouge because he's watching this from a
distance and he's seeing what's
happening and he knows me well enough
that he.
He could tell that I'm just frozen like
nothing's working,
what do I do next?
And I just needed that external force to
come in and say,
you're right,
nothing's working.
Here's why.
Let's take inventory.
Have you slept?
No,
I haven't slept for three days.
Maybe you ought to go try to take an
ambien.
At least get four hours of sleep.
It's that kind of stuff that makes a
huge event at that point.
Also with what was happening because of
the media.
You were sorta just in a feeding frenzy.
It was like a self fulfilling self
fulfilling,
right?
You know,
to this day I,
I'm always amazed.
I mean I could,
I could go through the litany of false
hoods,
um,
that I no longer defensive about because
they're false hoods and it is what it is
and I love talking about them in front
of,
you know,
corporate ceos and
Titans of industry who think they know
that they can run everything.
Well,
let me tell you,
someday the preferred,
the proverbial theses is going to hit
the fan and your company and you're
going to want to learn these lessons and
learn them.
Well.
That's why I run a small business here.
We have very little management.
Very good.
What do you make of just sort of the.
I guess this is just part of the human
condition,
the idea that we always need someone to
blame.
Now you are acknowledging that not
everything went right.
You didn't make every right decision.
We're acknowledging government over a
nonsense and all that,
but just this need to blame because I
think you are one of the first examples
because maybe it was sort of at the,
just at the beginnings of social media
or lines of just like,
let's just take this guy and we didn't
know who he was.
Yes,
and less just destroy it.
Let's just will destroy his career and
then we'll try to destroy his life.
What are you,
what do you make of just that general
psychological?
Well,
there is a,
um,
there's two ways to look at it.
In Judaism,
there is the philosophy of finding the
scape goat and putting all the sins of
the community,
putting all the sins of the village and
escape.
Let me go and throwing the gold over the
cliff.
Well,
I think that really is applicable to
life in general and we have through
social media.
I can't,
I can't even imagine what it would have
been like with social media
back in 2005.
It was brutal enough without it.
But I think we have,
when you think about the hierarchy of
needs that people have belonged,
love,
power,
social media has amplified all of those
and the,
the feeling of being superior to
somebody else so permeates our society
that any chance we have to squish
somebody,
it makes.
I don't know whether it's an endorphin
rush,
adrenaline,
but something that we now have this
horrible,
horrible desire to just destroy people.
They have lives.
They have families now.
Some people,
maybe they deserve it.
Maybe they don't.
But I,
I like to think that everybody,
unless you just totally a doofus,
people are actually trying to do the
best I can.
Yeah.
I mean I'm a firm believer in that,
but yes,
of course there are people that want to
just destroy.
Unfortunately,
I think social media has amplified the
best antidote
that heals me because I refused to stay
down.
There were people have actually advised
me you need to slither away.
And I was like,
are you kidding me?
I cannot wait for these congressional
hearings because I can't wait for some
dumb ass congressman or dumb ass senator
who thinks that he's God's gift of
creation to ask me a question because
I'm going to tell him the truth whether
he likes it or not.
So let's talk about this hearing's a
little bit when you see it.
Just not hearing right.
Any hearing related to anything else.
It strikes me as patently obvious that
pretty much the senators and congressmen
have almost no idea what they're talking
about really,
but they've been handed a brief and
they've been told by Prob,
you know,
a handler or whoever.
These are the three questions you got
asked cause we gotta get you on CNN
tonight so then you can push this and
blah blah.
Just did the hearings when they're
trying to unpackage all of this.
Did hearings ever make things better at
the end?
Like is there a hearing that ends and
then they go,
we really solved the problems of,
of why Katrina happened,
why the levees failed,
what the problems were with fema or were
there other responders,
etc.
Etc.
RarEly,
in fact,
let me tell you,
it's actually worse than what you think.
It's just more government growing.
It's moRe government growing.
But to tell you how bad it really is
there.
If as the under secretary,
if I'm going to testify now as a private
citizen when I testified in,
in the katrina,
the hearings
clear.
So how,
how long after the John Brown eight
until you until you resigned?
Well,
I,
I actually,
interestingly,
I resigned on September 11th of 2005,
but then they came to me and said,
oh we need you to stay on because we've
got to figure out just what's going on
because they're going to come after the
administration.
So we went to cow,
we want to keep you in the fold for
awhile.
So they kept me on as a consultant for
all right,
I want to say four or five months
afterwards.
And then I pulled the.
You must have been seriously pissed at
that because now you knew you were just
saying yes.
So I pulled the trigger and said no more
consulting.
I'm a private citizen and so when I'm
called to testify,
the white house has to do one of two
things.
They have to either accept that I'm
going to tell the truth or they have to
invoke executive privilege and prevent
me from testifying and we deliberately
settled up with Susan Collins and joe
lieberman for senator lieberman to ask
me a question,
so about conversations with the
president or the white house so that
when that question was asked,
my lawyer could say,
my client wants to answer the question,
but he cannot.
If the white house is going to invoke
executive privilege,
which then allowed senator lieberman see
how the charade works,
then allow senator lieberman to ask,
is there anyone in this hearing room
from the white house who wants to invoke
executive privilege?
And of course the room silent and
senator lieberman laughed and said,
oh,
I'm sure there are plenty of people from
the white house here,
but apparently nobody wants to invoke
executive privilege.
Mr.
Brown answer the questIon and boom,
we were off to the races,
but to go back about just a regular
hearing.
Yeah.
If an under secretary or any other
government official is going to go
testify,
his testimony is cleared through the
office of management and budget.
That testimony is given to the senators
and congressmen in advance.
The questions are given to the witness
in advance.
It is a show.
It is a production.
How much of it also is that they're
asking you things as if everything sort
of works perfectly in any of the
hearings.
You know when hillary,
the benghazi hearings where they're
asking minute by minute,
what did you say then to this person,
that person.
I mean,
I know in my own daily life you asked me
what happened three days ago at noon,
right?
You know,
I'd have to think about it for awhile,
but may I?
Maybe I can come up with it,
but just that they.
They're trying to get you on every
little thing.
Plus the pressures of your.
You're under oath,
you're the media watching and everything
else.
It just seems like it's a recipe
for nothing.
Nothing good,
nothing substantial to come out.
Nothing substantial does come out of
them now.
I think there's an exception if if in
the house or senate,
if they are truly conducting and
investigation,
and here's how to tell if they're truly
conducting your investigation,
they'll depose witnesses outside the
hearing room.
They will ask a witness either
voluntarily or with a subpoena to come
in and subject to a deposition by staff
lawyers.
That's a real investigation that's
really sitting you down and saying,
swear to tell the truth,
the whole truth,
nothing but the truth.
Now,
let us ask you a serIes of questions and
that can actually result in something
productive.
Now for the witness,
do you have to be very careful because
like anything else to your point,
why don't you do on wednesday at noon?
Um,
I,
you know,
I went to uh,
went to this bagel shop down the street
and have lunch.
What was the name of it?
Well,
I think it was x.
They find out actually you went to a
burger stand and had a burger.
Now they got you in perjury.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It really is crazy.
So what was the resolution and when the,
when the hearings ended,
like what,
what do they do?
So then they issue a report that report,
is there a prior brand and the report,
the report,
I get a kick out of this because the
report virtually acknowledged everything
that I had said was wrong about the
integration of fema and these other
agencies in the dhs.
There was a virtual admission to that
then the things that they wanted to do
to correct.
Uh,
we're,
I don't want to over exaggerate.
So let's just say 50 percent.
The nss dropped about 50 percent of the
things that I've been arguing about.
Now,
is it working?
It's not working Because the way things
go in dc,
whoever has the money has the power and
you can't wander.
I'm using the theme of current fema
director who's a former employee of mine
as an example.
you can't expect him on a day to day.
what's his name?
brock brock long.
Okay.
Used to be the at the national hurricane
center.
emergency manager in Alabama.
He's a great guy.
I love this guy.
Uh,
probably shouldn't have said that
because that will know.
Plus they'll regret having said that,
let's edit that out.
We donate It for you probably made his
Kenya everybody,
right,
exactly.
So we're,
we're,
uh,
well the reports and the report.
So if,
if you're fighting on a day to day basis
for your budget with the secretary of
homeland security and all the other
under secretaries,
and then when a disaster hits,
now you're the boss and the secretary is
subordinate to you.
Can you imagine knowing that in the
private sector one day you're the ceo,
but under certain circumstances you as
the ceo or actually subordinate to
somebody else on your staff.
I mean that's an untenable situation,
but that's kind of the situation they
created with the post katrina act.
That's crazy.
So we,
we touched obviously on the media
portion of this and I mentioned how when
I was googling you this morning as I'm
doing research,
half the articles come up are about the
10 year anniversary and they're still
attacking.
Yes.
Yeah.
Again,
you have sat here and acknowledge that
you did not do everything perfectly.
Right?
But what does,
what do you make of that in a more broad
sense about the media?
Because I talk about the media a lot
here and I'm extremely frustrated with
mainstream media and it's almost gotten
to the point where every time they write
something bad about somebody,
I started thinking that they're actually
the good guy because I see the way they
do it to me that the neo really has
completely gotten out of control.
They've.
They've lost,
they've lost all integrity,
they've lost all.
I'm just,
this is what I do on my own radio
program is I don't tell.
I don't ever try to tell people what to
think.
I try to give them a different
perspective so that they can,
with their own minds.
Maybe think about something a different
way.
The media,
if you look for those 10 year
anniversary things or there's a one
example that just stands out to this
date irritates me.
I had the highest level of security
clearances with the cia.
The nsa had a q clearance with the
department of energy,
which means I had access to all the
secrets and everything else.
I mean,
I,
I top secret special access programs.
That was me.
I don't know if you're going to drop any
other secret knowledge while you're
right,
if you're right.
So I had all these clearances and
everything else.
Time magazine ran a story that I had
lied on my resume.
Now my first reaction when they ran that
story was sued the bastards.
I want to go after him and then my
lawyer starts explaining to me,
okay,
um,
first of all,
you're going to have to prove they did
it with willful malice because you're a
public figure.
Then you're going to have to go through
all of the strain and time and energy of
depositions in a trial and hearings and
you want to relive all of that.
Or do you really care about time
magazine having some story that's now
10,
12,
15 years old about you lied on your
resume when you Know what the truth is.
And half of America knows what the truth
is and the other half of America you
don't really care about.
Yeah,
no,
but the media gets by with now I am not.
I am not.
Repeat.
Not going down the road,
the trump goes down that says we need to
change the libel laws.
I'm just pointing out that the media has
this amazing power and with that power I
believe countries possibility and
they've abdicated the responsibility.
Yeah.
You don't 50 Slash 50 on the libel thing
and everyone that's watching the show
that I am an free speech.
Absolute statute is an absolute twice
there,
but I do believe in libel laws and I do
believe we should have laws to protect
privacy and a series of other things.
I don't know.
I would prefer that they don't be
changed because I don't think we need
the government doing anything.
I don't think we need more laws.
I don't think we need more regulations
or any of that.
Right.
There is something that I see so
consistently these days where they Just
pick somebody and it's awful.
I mean,
it's often people that I have on this
show Because they're right in the thick
of have important conversations and we
say one thing here and then I read the
article about it the day after and it's
literally the reverse or they cut the
word not right,
you know,
or didn't.
it's
what I have found that I find
fascinating and I know that media is in
this transition.
You let me look at what you and I are
doing.
They hate what you and I are doing right
now because it throws away our business
model out the window.
Yeah.
I think what the.
Like I'll.
I'll be doing a story on,
on air and I've got the article in front
of me and I'm a.
I'm a kind of a grammar nut and I'll
look at.
I'll go,
holy crap.
An editor never even looked at this.
The wall street journal.
You the stellar newspaper,
right?
Yeah,
I'd have.
They fired all their editors.
I find so many grammatical errors,
punctuation errors,
all.
I just think the media is in this flux,
so you add the flux With their agenda at
times their sloppiness.
You had all of those things together.
The media is just not filling their
fourth estate responsibilities.
Yeah.
So how do we clean up some of this
government stuff?
I suspect,
although you just saId you're not with
trump on the,
uh,
alIve,
but I suspect that there's a certain
amount of deregulation that he's doing
and cutting back some of these agencies
that you got to be pretty happy with
static about it.
When you think about this whole,
you'll find it so bizarre example,
but whether it's here in California,
back in Colorado,
wherever,
wherever we might might be.
I challenge people watching this go look
at any government office and I would bet
it's the nicest office building in your
community.
Now,
wait a minute.
Who paid for that?
The guys in the garage who were coming
up with the next big thing,
assam startup company or some guidance
working an eight to five blue collar job
that got his hands dirty and his nails
are cracked and he's working with his
hands like crazy.
They're paying for that is,
It shouldn't be the reverse fact.
Shouldn't the government actually be in
the garages?
Shouldn't they?
Actually be the ones that are in the
office buildings that you know,
they have to go up 20 elevatorS to get
to their offices instead of having all
the edifices that we allow them to use
and create and build.
We have this,
we have this perverted sense that the
government,
and I think it's getting worse,
that the government is the answer to
everything and that somehow government
is going to solve all of our problems.
Let tell you the government doesn't
solve problems.
The government causes problems.
So what would you say the answer is
related to?
So at dhs or fema now or anything else?
I mean if these things didn't exist,
I'm sure somebody is watching this right
now.
What do you mean?
I mean if these things didn't exist,
well now you know new orleans still is
below sea level,
which is a whole in that.
That was just talking about that for a
second.
There are a certain amount of people
that now say,
well,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Because they don't realize it.
Then they hear it and they go,
wait a minute.
We have a city that's below sea level
that has all of these structural
problems.
Maybe we shouldn't be living there
anymore.
What do you say to someone like that?
First of all,
I think anybody should be able to live
wherever they want to live.
If if,
if I want to live next to the national
forest in boulder county,
Colorado,
I should be able to do that,
but then I should also assume the risk
of living there.
If I want to live on the fault lines in
California,
I should be able to do that,
but I should assume the risk.
Yeah,
I think government has some basic
services to provide.
We all agree the police protection,
fire protection,
that's something we all want to pay for,
but if you're going to deliberately
choose to live below sea level and then
why should I want to be very careful.
I can feel it already.
Why it's slippery.
It's slippery because I think they
should be able to live there.
If you choose to live there though,
it's the responsibility of the taxpayers
that lived there to create those levies
and build those levies and maintain
those levees.
Because I don't live there.
It's not my responsibility.
I pay taxes to take care of the hazard
where I live and frankly I don't think
the government should take care of all
hazards because if we tried to start,
if we start trying to protect the
american population from all of the
hazards that we face,
we will end up with a totalitarian
government because there's too many
hazards.
So this is sort of the case where the
people that that were down there in new
orleans,
that ally,
it's not just.
I'm sure most of them had earned.
I can't say most,
but I'm sure a good portion,
at least in the people that had money,
had insurance and probably had flood
insurance and everything else,
but it's that afterwards,
all this federal money comes in to help
the rebuild.
But you're saying there perhaps that
that doesn't quite make sense.
Is that,
is that basically there will be people
who will say,
oh my god,
the former director of federal emergency
management agency is saying we should
revisit.
Absolutely.
We have a concept of federalism in this
country.
We have federal,
state and local government and at at the
top load,
let's reverse that.
We have the people,
we have local government,
state government and federal government.
That's the order and what we have done
is we've taken the federal government
and we've almost made them the local
fire department.
We've almost made them the local police
department and the many aspects.
That's actually true.
Tsa for example,
we've made them a local police
department.
Even though I want to be a lawyer here,
they have no law enforcement authority.
They just think they do,
but they have zero law enforcement
authority.
What does it actually mean?
They have zero law enforcement
authority.
I mean if they.
If you go through and you've got a knife
in your pocket like,
oh,
then they just hand you off to whoever
the local daniel,
you got to get a cup.
I think I'd get a cop.
They can.
They can arrest you,
they cannot detain you,
they can't do anything,
but they call themselves officers
because they wouldn't put on the mask of
authority because government always
wants to put on the mask of authority
because that's how you keep the citizens
kind of subdued.
No.
Well,
my whole point about female becoming
kind of this first responder,
the more we rely on the federal
government to come in after any sort of
disaster that weakened state and local
governments because they become more and
more dependent upon the federal
government.
So more and more things get nationalized
and the more things get nationalized,
the more we turn into a western european
socialist type government,
which we know it's not going to happen
in our lifetimes.
Don't get me wrong,
I'm not.
I'm the tinfoil hatS.
Not on,
but,
but I do believe that republics
eventually fail and we are on this path
that if we keep going down this path of
throwing more and more things up against
the wall for the federal government to,
to handle and take care of,
we will end up as a western european
socialist government and over
generations and generations that leads
to tyranny.
So then you must be digging trump on
this.
Oh,
and this stuff.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
The thing,
the thing that bothers me,
look,
the president wasn't my first choice and
I,
before we go too deep and I do want to
mention that we are taping this a little
bit in advance of when it's going to
air.
So I just want to be very,
very clear.
But who knows what happened to the guys.
Um,
it wasn't my first choice,
but when it came down to the,
to the typical dichotomy of republican
versus democrat have,
you know,
I still think I still want to believe
that republicans or the government of
individualism and individual liberty and
everything,
although I could argue that they aren't
necessarily that way and the democrats
are moving to the hard progressive,
almost marxist left.
So when it comes to the general
election,
if I want to vote for one of those two,
I'm going to vote for trump.
I only say that because he has totally
up into what it means.
I work for george w dot buSh who people
thought couldn't speak well.
Um,
but I thought was smart,
knew what he was doing.
A,
I think trump is smart.
I think he knows what he's doing,
but he's the first president in this age
of twitter and facebook and everything
else.
And I just don't think we've quite
figured out how to deal with that.
And quite honestly,
I don't think he's quite figured out how
to deal with it.
He hasn't quite figured out that as
president,
if I say something even innocuous,
they're reading,
they're reading that in moscow,
they're reading that in pyongyang there,
reading it everywhere and so he needs to
be a little more.
I just wish it would be a little more
circumspect with use of social media.
Yeah,
right.
I know enough about trump.
Let.
Let's just talk about George W.
Bush for a second because you mentioned
he was.
He was your boss,
you know.
Well,
you know,
there was the caricature of course,
of all the years of his presidency that
he was some sort of idiot or you know.
Yes.
He had a strange way of speaking and
kind of stilted and met a lot of that
writing mixed up a lot of words.
Wow.
Tell me something about him that maybe
would give us a little other side that
we would know.
Sure.
There's an odd nostalgia.
That's what I'm saying.
There's an odd nostalgia about him now
because I see it from people on the left
all the time.
Now they're,
they're sort of galvanIzing him right
there.
There are lionizing him now.
He,
he and I were in the limo,
we were in the beast,
southern California,
going back to a marine one,
and we're on these kind of rural areas
and people have lined the streets and
eddie,
who was his agent in charge of
presidential detail,
he kept telling eddie,
and I wouldn't use these words
carefully,
eddie stop the car.
These people want to see their
president.
It wasn't eddie stopped the car.
They want to see me and he don't stop
the car because they want to see,
you know,
hey,
it's me and brown.
No,
they want to see their president.
He had this understanding of that office
was his temporarily and he was
everybody's president and I saw that in
that car and then I saw at one time in
the oval office we were sitting in and
press office comes through with a gaggle
of kids and he stops the meeting
entirely and shows these kids.
I mean they missed maybe sixth grade or
seventh graders.
Shows them the resolute desk and
explains to them the history of the
resolute desk and I'm sitting there
like,
oh,
I can watch this all day long.
Yeah.
Then a third story we.
It was the first presidential debate of
the 2004 election.
He,
gemini,
I in the car,
we'd been at some hurricane center
somewhere and jeb turns to him and says,
I think it's time to for you to go to
hotel,
you need to.
You really need to bone up and study
some bushes.
Like,
nah,
you know I'm going to whip his ass.
He was kind of a job.
He was kind of a frat boy alone.
He was kind of a frat boy,
jocular funding crack jokes,
you know,
smarted off.
I'm never inappropriately,
but just an ordinary human being.
So these two brothers get in a fight and
I'm sitting in the jump seat facing the
president,
like imu and jeb sitting there and
they're arguing about whether they
should go back to the hotel or now in
jeb looks at me and said,
lee,
and I'm like,
I am not going to the fight between two
brothers,
one who's the governor of a swing state
that we've got to witness election then,
and the other guy happens to be the
president.
United stAtes in my boss.
I'm staying out of that pipe boys and
what happened?
I stayed out of the fight and bush went
to the first debate and lost big time to
john kerry.
Very good.
Well listen,
it's really been a pleasure talking to
you.
I hope we cleaned up some of this stuff.
Did we hit everything that that
should've been hit on?
Are you kidding?
I,
I mean,
I know we four more days that.
Yeah,
you gotta go do your radio show.
Not too far from here,
but I suspect we'll do this again.
I hope so.
Yeah,
it was a pleasure.
Absolutely.
Oh,
and by the way,
I want to mention I've talked to the
people over here,
for those of you that follow us on
patriot on so many of you know that my
dog,
emma,
is a rescue from hurricane katrina and
she's got a really wonderful story.
Uh,
so we did a video of,
of michael meeting amma before and I,
and I told her story and that's an
unpatriotic and for more on michael and
you can follow him on twitter.
it's at Michael Brown,
usa.